شكرا فيدا اذا تحليل عسكري لمجريات
الاحداث في حرب اسرائيل على غزه وارحب
باللواء فائز دوير الذي يكون معنا دائما
في التحليل العسكري والاستراتيجي ولكن قبل
ان نبدا لنشاهد هذا الفيديو
[موسيقى]
الجديد
ا
[موسيقى]
ا كان هذا فيديو قد نشر ويتحدث فيه الاسرى
والمحتجزين وفي رساله واضحه للاسرائيليين
بعدم الثقه برئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
فيما يتعلق بتحرير المحتجزين يعني اللواء
فايز هذا ياتي في ظل واقع انه حتى الان لم
يتم تحرير اي اسير او محتجز في قطاع غزه
من قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بل
بالعكس قتلوا على ايديهم ورساله هنا واضحه
لنتنياهو يعني اتصور انه بعد 91 يوم كما
ذكرتي لم يتم اطلاق سراح اي رهينه لكن من
خلال هدنه سبعه ايام اطلق سراح اكثر من
100 ونتنياهو لديه مشكلاته خاصه بعد قرار
المحكمه العليا مما وضعه في مازق هو يهرب
الى الامام مصلحته الشخصيه فوق كل اعتبار
فجاء هذا الفيديو اعتقد وقعوا على اهل
الاشر اكثر ايلاما حتى الفيديوهات التي
تدمر فيها الدبابات
والناقلات لكن هنا اشاره واضحه يعني كانهم
يقولوا ان نتنياهو مصاب بعقده نفسيه مزمنه
منذ عام 76 لانه عمليه مطار عنتيبي في تم
اختطاف طائره فرنسيه وا ذهبت الى مطار
عنتيبي في اوغندا بعد ذلك
اي تم اطلاق سراح كافه الرهائن ابقي على
الرهائن اليهود كان عددهم تقريبا 103
وقطعت الطائرات
الاسرائيليه 100
جندي ذهبوا لمسافه 4000 كيل متر ويطلق
عليها بعض الحالات عمليه جونثان بالنسبه
الى اخو نتنياهو الذي قتل في تلك العمليه
و ما اعتقد كان ملازم اول فكانهم يقولوا
نتنياهو غير مكترث نتنياهو الان همه ان
ينقذ نفسه من مشكلات الفساد ويرغب بان
يجعلكم تعانوا ما عاناه عندما قتل اخوه في
عمليه تحرير عش فبالتالي هي رساله واضحه
واعتقد سيكون لها صد داخل المجتمع في
الكيان الاسرائيلي وهو ما سنتابع في
الايام القادمه وربما الساعات القادمه
ايضا لوا فائز ابقى معنا لدينا المزيد
للتحليل وهنا نذكر مشاهدينا ان بيني جانس
كان قد تحدث قبل ساعات بالامس عن حديثه عن
انه لن تتوقف هذه العمليه وهذه الحرب حتى
انقاذ وتحرير كافه المحتجزين والاسرى هل
هناك انعكاس لما هذه لهه التصريحات على
الميدان سلام خضر بالفعل مياده ونراه بشكل
واضح في خان يونس
بالتحديد اذا سنبدا في التطورات الميدانيه
من جنوب قطاع غزه جنوب قطاع غزه مازال
يشهد قتالا عند اكثر من محور ولكن الجديد
هو ما تنقله وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه
تحدثت الى احد
قاده الوحدات المقاتله في جنوب قطاع غزه
واسمه الكولونيل ميكي شربت يقول اننا ناخذ
وقتا طويلا في العمليات العسكريه لاننا لا
نعرف الطبيعه الفعليه لجنوب القطاع القتال
مستمر منذ منذ اربعه اسابيع لكننا ما زلنا
نتعرف على طبيعه الجغرافيا وايضا طبيعه
المقاتلين في هذه الاثناء مدينه خانيونس
تستمر القتال فيها بشكل عنيف جدا كتائب
القسام التي تقاتل القوات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة
ولكن ما جرى اليوم هو انتقال القتال
العنيف الى الزنه الزنه هي يعني بحسب
الجغرافيا هي الى الشرق قليلا ويفترض ان
الدبابات الاسرائيليه عندما دخلت من حي
صلاح الدين ومن الجراره تحديدا انها انهت
القتال في الزنه الزنه اليوم هي محور قتال
عنيف جدا القتال ضار وهناك استهدافات
لتجمعات جنود ولاليات وايضا كتائب القسام
عندما يحتدم القتال وهذا ما لاحظناه يبدو
انها استراتيجيه يقوم بقصف المناطق التي
تتواجد فيها القوات الاسرائيليه ولو كانت
مناطق القتال سنذهب الى وسط القطاع البريج
والنصيرات
والزوي والمغازي ما زالت محاور اشتباك
وقصف عنيف هناك محاوله واضح اسرائيليه
اليوم للتوغل الى داخل مخيم البريج والى
داخل المغازي من المنطقه الغربيه هذا
يتوازى مع قصف عنيف عند النقاط الشرقيه
وشارك في القصف ايضا في استهداف المنطقه
الوسطى البوارج الاسرائيليه قصف من البحر
مكثف وهناك ايضا عمليات عسكريه مشتركه بين
كتائب القسام وسرايا القدس تستهدف
الاسرائيليين بطبيعه الحال اضافه الى قصف
في المناطق الشماليه هذه باختصار مياده
المجريات الميدانيه المزيد معك والمزيد
سنبدا من حيث انتهيت تحديدا سلام شكرا لك
اذا الوسط والجنوب هما الاكثر سخونه الان
في العمليات الدائره وهناك نمط جديد على
ما يبدو يتبعه
الاحتلال تقريبا خلال ال 24 36 ساعه
الماضيه من خلال متابعاتي بصوره حثيثه
لمجريات المعارك استطيع ان اضع تصور عام
هذا التصور الذي وصلت الذي وصلت له انه
بدا يغير في ادارته للمعركه تجزئه المجزا
فبالتالي هو الان اذا اخذنا منطقه الوسط
هي تعتبر جزء من
كل عمد الى قطع امكانيه التواصل فوق الارض
ما بين المخيمات سيارات البريج المغازي
الزوايده عبر شارع صلاح الدين عبر شارع
صلاح الدين دفع بلواء مدرع ولواء مظليين
لانه سابقا هو ركز على البريج ولاكثر من
عده ايام وكان يفشل ام فبالتالي حتى يحقق
نجاه بدايه العمليه كانت على صلاح الدين
وفشلت اعاد مره اخرى اعاد تجميع القوات
استطاع ان يدخل بالمنطقه المفتوحه ما بين
النصيرات والبريج الان البريج يهاجم من
ثلاثه اتجاهات يهاجم من الشرق يهاجم من
الشمال يهاجم من المنطقه الغربيه كذلك
مغازي يهاجم من الجنوب ومن المنطقه
الغربيه ان صيرات يهاجم من الشرق ومن
الزاويه الشماليه الغربيه الزوايده لا
يزال الامر اقل حده من هذه الامور ما لفت
انتباهي انه في هذه المناطق والى الشمال
منها منطقه القراره
اي كان امر ملفت للانتباه انه كذلك هاجمها
من ثلاثه اتجاهات ام اي في منطقه القراره
وفي ال المغرا اها
المنطقتين طبيعه العمليات
متقاربه حتى في الزنه وفي خزاعه هذه
الاربع مناطق يهاجمها من ثلاثه اتجاهات
فبالتالي كانه بدا يوظف العقيد القتاليه
الامريكيه التي استخدمها في الفلوجه
استخدمها في الرقه استخدمها في عده اماكن
في سوريا وفي العراق مع اختلاف الظروف
المكانيه يعني لم يستطع ان ان نفذها
بالمطلق في مدينه الموصل لانه مساحتها
وسيعه والظروف الميدانيه مختلفه فبدا الان
يحاول ان يحاصر هذه البلدات الصغيره
والمناطق الصغيره و على مبدا ما يطلق ما
يمكن ان نسميه القضم المتدرج انه يهاجم من
ثلاث اتجاهات في بعض الحالات من اربع
اتجاهات كل ما يحرز تقدم يحاول ان يتمسك
به يضاف الى ذلك كثف من القصف الجوي وال
المدفعي
اي لحتى غايات مساف مسافه الامان بالنسبه
لجنوده ليمنع امكانيه تقديم اسناد متبادل
عن هذا يعني ان المعارك الان قد تاخذ وقت
اطول خاصه ان صحيفه جيروزالم بوست كانت
تحدثت عن تقدم تدريجي هذا هذا ما اود ان
اقوله عندما نقول القدم المتدرج هذا يعني
هو سيقوم بعمليه قتال
مستميت سيعمل على
التطهير تدمير الانفاق هذا يدخل في دوامه
الاطار الزمني واعتقد انه غير متاح له
وغير متوفر في المنطقه
الجنوبيه بلغ عدد الالويه ثمانيه الويه
دفع بلواء اعاد اي بناء لواء جولاني الذي
سحبت منه الكتيبه 13 الان دفع به كلوا
ثامن تعمل في ن سقين لكن العقده الرئيسيه
له الان يحاول ان يلين الاطراف في منطقه
بني سيله وعبس وعبس الكبيره لانها منطقه
واسعه ويبدو انه لا يجر على التقدم فاعاد
الان التركيز على الزنه والقرار وخزاعه ا
حتى يضعف الاكتاف الحامله للمعركه
الرئيسيه من اجل يح ان يحقق تقدم ب يجتاز
من خلاله شارع صلاح الدين ويعزز العمليات
التي تجري الان في الشمال الغربي والشمال
من خان يونس هذا الامر سياخذ وقت لكن ادا
الا المقاومه بناء على ما يصدر من
المقاومه لا تزال متماسكه ولا تزال توقع
خسائر كبيره في قوات العدو زنه وحدها كان
هناك ثلاث عمليات نوعيه تم الاعلان عنها
اليوم تم تدمير دبابتين وتم تدمير ناقله
ناقل الجند وتم تفجير ثلاث عبوات ضد
الافراد في حق الالغام كان في سبعه جنود
وبالتالي الخسائر كبيره بس الجانب
الاسرائيلي لا يعلن يعني الان اذا انتظرنا
الناطق العسكري سيتحدث حث عن جرحه يعني
الملاحظ انه في الفتره الاخيره بدا يصرح
كثيرا باعداد قتلى فقط يتحدث عن جرحه وما
شابه ذلك لكن اعتقد الواقع بناء على ما
ياتي من الفيديوهات
الجرح ان يتم التصنيف ان هناك حوالي 12 ال
هم قد يكونون معرضون لان يكونوا معاقين في
اقل من دقيقه هذه الان اصابات الاطراف
عندهم هي هاجس اصبحت يعني عمليه الاصا
الاطراف تعطيل اليد او تعطيل القدم
وشاهدنا فيديوهات يصرخ انه يدي غير موجوده
قدمي غير موجوده اصابه كلما لاحظتي ان
هناك طائرات تنقل الجرحى تاكدي ان
هناك جرحى بحاله خ شكرا جزيلا لك لواء
فائز الدويري